and poison Amy's from Batman and why did
you decide to come dressed as poison ivy
my friend is here as Harlequin so we
were going to do poison ivy Harlequin
thing so she's around some like what
kind of reaction are you getting but the
crowds here because she looked pretty
amazing thank you and we've had a lot of
people come up to me and just stop me
and say oh can we get a picture there
and I'm like yeah that's fine and then
other people will see that they're
getting pictures so they'll get pictures
so I've heard of you there was already
it's pretty good and what you liked
about poison ivy in particular I just
like how she's you know femme fatale
she's she's cool too she kills people
with kisses all that sort of stuff so
that's fine with me
have you been killing anyone with kisses
here yes not yet nobody's asked one so
you know everyone's safe they might know
that if they do they might die or
something you could take the whole place
out behind one of those signers had free
kisses good news absolutely it's
probably best that I don't do it so I'm
just just gonna take pictures that say
tell me a little bit about you costume
how did you put it together and
basically I just I bought this corset so
that was the first thing and the wig and
then these are just them I showed all of
these ivy leaves onto my shorts and I
sent them all here as well and that's
basically basically sewing you and you
just got some green tights on their
birth posted lady yep and I did have
shoes on yesterday but they had a little
bit so I took them off today was more
comfortable that way the fantastic wig
as well you got there thank you I just
probably like spare ivy in the back and
all that sort of stuff
give us a 12o and again
looking fantastic so do you normally
come to these events on a dressed-up and
this is the first one but since it's the
first one I've just thought yeah I'll
dress up I'll go all out this time so
see what have you learned about being
poison ivy that you're gonna take into
your next cosplay event that she gets a
lot of pictures a lot of people like to
get pictures with that I saw a guy came
up to me yesterday and he's like I have
a thing for poison ivy so I'm just gonna
take a picture in here so it's good
you